i'm ready to be with someone who knows
what they want surprise
matt james is our new bachelor yeah i'm
stoked
the news was revealed friday morning
making him the franchise's very first
black bachelor in its 18-year history
it's
long the announcement was made on good
morning america amid worldwide headlines
about the black lives matter movement
in a press release abc explained quote
this
is just the beginning and we will
continue to take action with regard to
diversity issues on this franchise
we feel so privileged to have matt as
our first black bachelor
and we cannot wait to embark on this
journey with him et spoke exclusively to
matt back in march when he was getting
ready to film claire crawley season of
the bachelorette but filming was put on
hold
because of coronavirus concerns i hope
things work out with you and claire but
if not
matt for bachelor i'm ready now i hope
it works out with her too so hopefully
we want to get to that point but would
you say no to it
well hopefully we won't get there
hopefully i'll be with claire so on
friday the 28 year old said he was
disappointed he wouldn't get to meet
claire
but that he's excited to take on the
lead role it's an honor you know i'm
just going to lean into myself
and how my mom raised me and hopefully
when people invite me into their homes
on monday night they're going to see
that
i'm not much different from them and
they see the diverse love stories are
beautiful
he was also asked if he felt the
franchise had done too little too late
when it came to casting him you know my
opinion i don't think it's ever the
wrong time to do the
i don't think it's ever the wrong time
to do the right thing so
too little too late for me is is this
happening and
we can't have change until you put that
first foot forward bachelor nation was
fast to weigh in too former bachelorette
hannah brown
is totally stoked what the heck
matt james is a bachelor i
literally just spoke up and i could not
be
more excited y'all should be so freaking
excited because this is like the best
human being in the entire world
y'all this is amazing as is matt's best
friend and roommate
bachelorette fan favorite tyler cameron
who revealed he was with matt during his
interview
posting this behind-the-scenes video to
his insta story
writing let's go former bachelorette
rachel lindsay is the franchise's only
other black lead
and has been vocal about her
disappointment over the lack of
diversity amongst the leads on the show
if no one else is going to speak on it
then i guess it's my duty to say it
the bachelor franchise has vowed to work
on diversity in recent years
and has made changes peter weber's
season had the most diverse cast ever
but earlier this week rachel told et why
she was ready to sever ties with the
franchise
if more wasn't done but i don't want to
be affiliated with
a franchise who's not on the right side
of this
at this time at this point you can't be
neutral you're either on the wrong side
or the right side
and the franchise to me has been on the
wrong side for 18 years
for 40 seasons but on friday morning abc
executive rob mills told variety
matt's casting quote wasn't a response
to rachel's threat to disassociate with
the franchise
and he hopes the announcement gives
people a bit of optimism
i'm looking for something meaningful
that's really what i'm excited about
so just who is matt james matt
and tyler went to wake forest university
together
what advice did he give you he just said
be yourself uh
and just be true to that and that's kind
of what i'm gonna do i mean
that's that's all you can do is just be
who you are and if it goes well for you
than it was meant to be
they quarantined together in florida
amid the coronavirus pandemic
where they tick-tocked a lot
the two are so close that tyler's late
mom
andrea actually played a big part in him
joining the cast of the bachelorette
she had nominated me and i think she saw
everything that it did for tyler and the
way that he had changed as a man
and me being his roommate and being one
of her sons i think that she wanted
something like that for myself
she'd be happy to know that that i
followed through with it matt graduated
from college in 2015
with a degree in economics and he gave
himself a year to make it in the nfl
while matt didn't end up making the cut
so he shifted gears and worked at a bank
in pittsburgh
before moving to nyc to work as a
research analyst at a commercial real
estate company
and get ready to swoon because matt
loves working with kids
he started abc food tours an
organization which provides culinary
experiences to underserved elementary
school students
sounds like the perfect man for our next
bachelor
right i think i'm grounded you know i uh
a lot of things that i've done
uh leading up to this point just making
sure that i'm having constant
conversations with my mom people that
i'm not gonna be around for a while
and that i love and respect to just kind
of put me in the right mindset to
to make sure i'm doing everything that
would make them proud so